نحييكم مشاهدينا من جديد في العراق مواقف
متباينه حملتها زياره قائد فيلق القدس
الايراني اسماعيل التي جاءت بالتزامن مع
زياره ثانيه للمبعوث الامريكي الخاص للشرق
الاوسط سبرت ماكر مسؤول بارز في الاطار
التنسيقيه رفض الكشف عنهويته اكد ان
زيارتين خطط لهما في وقت سابق او خطه
بهدف في فتح حوار المباشر بين دولتيهم
بشكل غير عالمي وهنا يرى مراقبون انا
بغداد يمكن ان تلعب دورا ناقلي رسائل بين
الطرفين حول ملفات عالقه بين دولتين كل
هذه تحركات زمنت مع تصريحات السوداني
بخصوص الوجود العسكري الامريكي في البلاد
والتي تواصل ترحل مزيد من الجدل في الوسط
السياسي
[موسيقى]
مناقش هذا الموضوع مع ضيوفنا من بغداد
الدكتور عدنان سراج رئيس المركز العراقي
لتنميه الاعلاميه اهلا بك من واشنطنطينيه
اهلا بكم
الكريمين
دكتور عدنان
نعم شكرا على الاستضافه تحيه لك ولضيفك
العزيز مشاهديكي الكرام
انا اقول اليوم الحدث العراقي وتفاعلات
الحدث التي يعقب عمليات التفاهمات
الموجوده في المنطقه وخصوصا بعد التطورات
الرئيسيه هناك التطورات الرئيسيه تحصل في
المنطقه هناك تغيير في السياسات
اليوم تجدين المملكه العربيه السعوديه
بدات في منهاج جديد واسلوب جديد في
التعامل مع العراق وكذلك العراق بدا بتعام
جديد مع الجمهوريه اسلام الايرانيه ومع كل
الدول المنطقه في ذلك اعتقد هذه الزيارات
ستكون متتاليه
تعتبر بانه هناك تقارب عراقي مع دول
المنطقه في حين تغير في وجهه نظر العراقيه
تجاه ايران
لا اعتقد بهذا الشكل ولكن بشكل المتوازن
يعني اليوم المنطقه ايضا هي تغيرت نظرتها
تجاه العراق يعني ليس العراق فحذف العراق
الان يريد من ايران ويريد من دول العربيه
ان تكون بطريقه اداره الازمه يعني لا تكون
العلاقه مع محل خلافات
هل يريد فعلا ان يكون في دور وسيط بين
واشنطن وزهران او ان لواشنطن حساباتها
ثنائيه مع بغداد
العراق يريد من واشنطن ان تكون اكثر
عقلانيه واكثر مرونه في التعامل لا تجعل
العراق في المواقف حرجه تجاه الجمهوريه
الاسلاميه الايرانيه او اتجاه اي دوله
اخرى العراق يريد من امريكا ان تساهم فعلا
في تحافظ على استقرار العراق وتطبق
الاتفاقيات الاطار التعاون الاستراتيجي
وان تكون مدينه في تعامل العراق مع الدول
العربيه مع الدول المجاوره خصوصا تركيا
او العراق في مواقف محرجه وبان بغداد تطلب
من امريكا ان تغير بعض طريقه او او بعض
المواقفها وطريقه تعاملها مع الجانب
العراق
بصراحه كامل انا اتفق مع الزمير المحترم
انه
العراق يجب ان تكون مجال ااا مستقر
ونعمل توازن بين تاثيره والوجود الايراني
في هذا البلد من ناحيه والوجود الغربي
والامريكي من ناحيه اخرى في نفس الوقت انا
اتفق مع كل ذلك وانا اعتقد انه الاداره
الامريكيه
المعنى انه هناك مشاكل لوجود عسكري امريكي
محدود في العراق في نفس الوقت انه نحن
كلنا نعترف بان ايران دوله كبيره قويه
مجاوره للعراق ولذلك لا بد من تاثير
ايراني محدود كمان داخل هذا البلد العربي
داخل العراق لذلك انا لا اعتقد ان هناك
خلافات همم جوهريه بين النظريه العراقيه
والنظريه الامريكيه بالنسبه لتاثير
الايراني في المنطقه وفي العراق بشكل خاص
لكن في ناس الوقت انا اخالف مع نظريات
المؤامرات التي تقول ان هناك عراقيه بين
طهران
لا في بغداد ولا في اي مكان انا اعتقد انه
الخلافات الايرانيه
بيكيه
عميقه جدا وصعبه جدا بالنسبه للمنطقه بشكل
عام على الرغم من
احتمال تعايش
في الاراضي العراقيه
في بغداد في نفس توقيت زياره قراني
[موسيقى]
نعم من تنسيق بالنسبه لهذا التوقيت
والجدير بذكر انه هناك عامل شخص
ل- اا توقيت زياره همم
عائله عمار الحكيم همم ولذلك انا اعتقد
انه توقيت من ناحيه همم واشنطن همم كان
تاكيد على
استمرار الوجود العسكري الامريكي في
العراق ونحن نرحب بشده الكلام السيد
السوداني الذي قال اخيرا انه هو يتوقع
ويرحب باستمرار هذا الوجود العسكري
الامريكي
الكبيره في الواقع في العراقي همم دكتور
رعد 2 ااه طرح ضيفي يضعف او حتى يلغي
فرضيه الوساطه العراقيه بين طهران واشنطن
هو يقول بانه شرخ عميق وبغداد لن تقدر على
شيء فتبقى لنا فرضيه وحيده وهي فرضيه
الحسابات الثنائيه بين واشنطن وبغداد
والعنوان الابرز هذه المرحله هو القوات
الامريكيه القوات الاجنبيه في العموم
والقوات الامريكيه في داخل العراق هل هذا
هو الملف الابرز لهذه الزياره
يعني انا اعتقد زياره الواطيه الامريكي
بعنوانها العام هو من الطاقه يعني الوفد
بج- يتطرق الى هذه القضيه قضيه الامن
للطاقه الذي هو الان شغل الشاغل بالنسبه
لامريكا والعالم الغربي خصوصا في قضيه
الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه هذه قضيه تشغل
الاداره الامريكيه خصوصا اذا استمرت الحرب
طويلا فلذا كانت النقاشات حسب مصادر
العراقيه تدور حول هذه المساله والدوره
العراقي في هذا الموضوع
دكتور عدنان الطاقه
قبل الطاقه يشمل العديد من الحفاظ على
تدفق النفط والغاز وايضا التعاون للمنطقه
في بسه تامين الامن في الخليج
والمضايق الاخرى واضافه لذلك لتوفير
الامكانيات الكامله للشركات بان تعمل بشكل
يعني امن من خلال الاتفاقيات التي بينها
بين الدول الاخرى اذا تخفيف التوترات في
المنطقه خصوصا في منطقه الخليج العربي وفي
مناطق اخرى انا اتصور هذا الموضوع موضوع
مهم ايضا
هذه النقطه لو سمحتي
هل يمكن ان نشهد معادله الطاقه مقابل
اعاده او بقاء القوات الامريكيه في داخل
العراقي همم في استجابه لتصريحات السيد
السوداني
انا اتمنى ذلك لكن
الحقائق في الميدان للاسف صعبه بالنسبه
للاستثمارات الامريكيه والشركات العظمى
الامريكيه في مجال النفط او في
مجالات اخرى المعنى انه
ال ااه
للاسف المشهد
الداخلي العراقي بالنسبه للفساد بالنسبه
للامن بالنسبه للتغيرات السياسيه غير
المتوقع وعدم الاستقرار في البلد كل هذه
العوامل تعرقل همم التعاون الاقتصادي بين
امريكا والاراق وانا شخصيا انا اعتقد انا
اشعر انه هذا
الحزين وانا اتمنى تغيرات في هذا المشهد
في المستقبل
ضيف يقول بانه عمليات او ملفات الفساد
ستعطل هكذا تعاون بين الجهتين
لا بالتاكيد الفساد مؤثر بشكل عام على
الواقع المعيشه وعلى الواقع الاقتصادي
وعلى واقع الاستثمار العراق يسعى جاهدا
الى ان يفتح الابواب ويشجع المستثمرين
للعمل في داخل العراق وخصوصا الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه لدينا اتفاقات والذين
يعني بتعاون كبير في هذا المجال لكن واقع
الحال يقول اكثر من ذلك اليوم العراق
يتوجه الى اوروبا على امريكا لا تتحسس من
تعاوننا مع فرنسا مع المانيا مع بريطانيا
مع ايطاليا خصوصا هؤلاء قد بداوا بزيارات
علاقات
اثنين
الطاقه بالنسبه للقوات الاجنبيه ماذا لو
همم طفق على بقاء القوات الاجنبيه فدخل
العراق
لعبه تاكيد الواقع الارقام القوات
القتاليه في العراق هذا متفق عليه بين
الطرفين بين الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
وبين العراق في زمن العبادي في زمن
الكاظمي تم الاتفاق وتم تثبيت هذا الامر
على ان تتكون
من البرنامج
استشاره شيء اخر اتحدث عن القوات العسكريه
الامريكيه كان هناك قرار البرلمان يؤكد
الزاميه خروجهم
نعم خروجه وخروج القوات الاجنبيه كافه
ولكن يعطي صلاحيات لرئيس الحكومه ببقاء
المدربين وايضا استشاريين وهذا ما يحصل
اليوم كل القوى السياسيه منتفخه على ان
العراق
وليس النقاط على التقاء على كل
سنعود لنناقش هذه النقاط اول شكرا لكم
جزيل الشكر من بغداد الدكتور عدنان سراج
رئيس المركز العراقي للتنميه الاعلاميه
ومن واشنطنبول هو كان مستشار السابق في
وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه وكبير الباحثين
في عهد واشنطن لي سياسه الشهداء الادنى
لنقاش دائما بقيه مشاهدينا السلام عليكم
[موسيقى]